my father was a great
man a hero so they
say sometimes the world doesn't need
another
hero sometimes what it
needs is a
monster
my
prince I've missed you something
troubles
you the sulan is preparing for battle
and requires 1,000 boys for his
army including your
son run to your mother look
away you can't protect us I'll find a
way
I have been waiting an
eternity for a man of your strength to
arrive welcome to your
life what is it you are seeking I want
the power to destroy my enemies and save
my family's
no
drink
Dracula welcome to your
Li what's happening to you I'm nothing
thing men fear not a ghost something
else find you I see the devil inside
him do you think you are alive because
you can
fight you are alive because of what I
did to save
you the
world never forget who I
am